you see that uh california regional
democrat who says we need to deprogram
75 million americans
and then the responses were like this is
why they have gulags
so the crazy thing about it is this guy
thinks literally all 75 million trump
supporters
are like fanatical conspiracy like
psychopaths running around screaming
when in fact the overwhelming majority
of trump's voters are probably like some
dude who was like who should i vote for
well trump seems to be for unions and
then that's it he's been doing fine
that's why i voted for him is
he's fine i don't i don't see any reason
to change it there's a lot of people who
voted for trump who are like not
political
yeah so so when you know when you see
these videos of like the q anon people
or like the really diehard trumpers
that's a small fraction of trump's base
yeah they're they're vocal there's
there's many of them it's probably in
the millions
but most trump supporters are probably
just like i don't know man you know i
think trump's going to do better with
the economy
i didn't get a 600 fine for not having
obamacare so exactly
you did no i didn't yeah trump's in
office no yeah that's my buddy
i didn't appreciate that at all it's i
was already broke i didn't want to sign
up for it
right so i get fined it's like bro
you're you're stealing money out of my
pocket i'm just this poor
yup i'm already poor yeah i can't and i
don't want to sign up for things like
this
it's uh i didn't it disagreed with me
morally uh
i i don't i don't feel like i should
reach in other people's pockets and take
money out of there and i mean that's
what taxes are i suppose some people
can't argue but
yeah it is and and to varying degrees
you know
i was looking at a chart i think it's
only the one percent for the most part
that pays taxes
most uh most people in this country
under a certain
uh income they pay taxes but they
receive
more from the government more value more
monetary value than they actually pay is
that including like
roads and yeah fire departments like
every every benefit you get
is a net negative for the government
except for the rich people who are
paying
progressively more taxes yeah okay well
that sounds functional
yeah right that sounds really i mean and
and the problem is the left response is
tax the rich and it's like
okay where how much like what percentage
like what are we talking about
and then you hear about this plan for
like a wealth tax it sounds to me like
there's too much coming from the left
the progressives that is literally just
them saying
burn the country to the ground plus the
panama papers did you guys study those
at all when those came out a little bit
that was a while ago it was like all the
people out there
money yeah in panama and other places
but there's lots of rich people will
just store their money over
offshore especially if you start to tax
them hard they'll put into assets
overseas
illegally hide it yeah yeah they can
start you can start a company in a
different country
to have your money your income go into
and then you don't have to pay taxes on
it it's crazy
arguably you do but like these people
find these loopholes
it's like a bad bad chess game we're far
worked way too far
both sides are losing and if you were
analyzing the game you have to say okay
around
turn 20 everything went bad for both of
us we lost all our pieces
we're just going around our kings are
circling each other can we just restart
or can we
rewind the game you got to call it
stalemate no no it's not
it's not about at turn 20 something
things went wrong it's about at a
certain point the democrats decided
repealing the civil rights law in
california was a good idea
would you would you ever like would you
compromise if if like so the democrats
were like look
the we want to repeal civil rights laws
notably this one in california
and and give the government the right to
discriminate in the basis of race
will you compromise maybe would you
would
would you be okay if we only
discriminate on the basis of certain
races
no you would you compromise at all with
that position or would you say
civil rights law must remain they've
been you don't you say like give them an
inch they take a foot you know something
like that given that you take a mile
right it's they've been doing it for a
long time it's just maybe now
their boulder with their demands we've i
say we but
they've been getting their way for a
very long time now they feel more bold
and just saying you know what i'm going
to take the whole table i'm not going to
just take this one piece of cake
well the the issue i see is because i
was talking to my friend and she was
saying look we got to figure a way to
bring people together and like move
forward as a country and i was like i
completely agree
so if you can figure out a way to
convince the people who want to repeal
civil rights law in california it failed
by the way because the people of
california voted against it
if you can figure out a way to convince
them to stop doing that then i think
we'll have unity
but you can't because they're saying
you're the racist for allowing these
anti-discrimination laws well they've
been doing it anyway
on your say i ran an application i want
to work for
tim incorporated and there's a little
line that says uh
if you want to write down your race and
gender here and if i
choose not to answer those that means
i'm one of those pesky people with
opinions
you're not going to hire me so they've
they've had those lines in the
applications i've tried to work in the
animation industry and stuff like that
so i know these things
i'm a genius uh so i'm just kidding but
they're serious they have they have
softly been screening for
this kind of thing for many years they
just so happened that they felt bold
enough to put it now into law the
companies have been doing it forever
so the issue though is there is such a
fundamental difference right now between
the two
realities there is no compromise though
you can compromise on some things
probably
but some of the stuff they're proposing
is just so downright psychotic
it's like you're you're not going to
compromise on that and that and then you
can't bring people together
when you have like that story in texas
where the dad says his kid is not trans
and the mom says the kid is
and the mom wants to put the kid on you
know treatment and medical treatment
which can permanently alter the kid for
the rest of his life
that's like there's no middle ground
there i think we need to think of it
as religious in religious terms like
we're looking at
we say religion is like follow this book
but really
it's like a set of rules it's like an
operating system perhaps you can put it
that way
some people have mac installed some
people have windows installed you got in
this case the mom had mac or
pc whatever the dad had the other
operating system
links right there ubuntu completely yeah
we think completely differently uh the
human mind maybe
is just a computer without an operating
system installed but we're taught to
say okay we're going to view the world
okay in china this is what the world is
like this is what is right and wrong
this is how you should behave in other
countries maybe they're more religious
they say this is the operating system
we're going to install in your head and
for some people maybe the operating
system
is more deeply installed in other cases
maybe you lose your religion something
like that but
we have a sort of form of secularism uh
devotion to the state perhaps depending
on okay let's say if
uh if someone says i stand for x y and z
they are told oh then you're in this
party therefore you have to believe all
these other things because you're on our
team now
right i don't like being on a team i
just i kind of buffet style this is what
i believe here
maybe i'll change i believe a little bit
of this but obviously
well so so like the one one another
issue another example is
do you know how many unarmed black men
were shot and killed by police last year
i remember you saying it was like 20
says i'll give you i'll give you the
high end
13. yeah the low end is nine depending
on which source you use
13. when i hear that i say it does not
sound like after 375 million
interactions between police and and you
know civilians
that we have a wide or systemic problem
with police targeting
you know people of color or something
like that but black lives matter
believes they do so they go out and they
riot
it feels higher to them i would say well
i mean it's a media issue
i've got a friend who he always jokes he
used to joke about uh
being pulled over for driving while
black he would say uh
things like that he's terrified of the
police and he i'm sure he's heard
stories about people getting beaten up
or whatever
bad stories and could that be what's
driving it that fear story just the
stories
they're afraid of understandably police
being cruel to them i get it when i was
i i hear all this talk this these
stories about the talk right yeah where
they say like you know they say black
families have to give their kids the
talk about how to deal with cops
and the weirdest thing to me is like i
went through that talk yeah like my dad
sat me down and said we have a
discussion about what you do when you're
stopped by the police and i was like
maybe i guess we're you know we're a
mixed race family from the south side of
chicago so maybe that's it we're not the
privileged white people from the suburbs
i guess
but i hear a ton of people of different
races who have the talk
but for some reason the median narrative
makes it specifically about you know
only black people
but i'm not trying to get into whole
black lives matter thing i'm bringing up
just to say
the fundamental world view is completely
is is divergent there's no
there's no bringing that together so you
end up with people marching through the
streets smashing things burning things
down and destroying things
and when i say hey you shouldn't do that
they say you need to understand their
pain it's like well i
i'm not going to compromise with that
there's no amount of writing i'm going
to say that's
that's the okay amount one way you can
think of it is i like this metaphor
about each of us having our own
operating system and certain people have
a different operating system than you do
so you've got linux they've got
windows and certain mind viruses can
only infect you if you're running a
specific type of operating system
so this mind virus that's making those
people crazy only affects their
operating systems
it doesn't affect you and you're
incapable of understanding the virus
because it doesn't
it doesn't function with your operating
system me out so in order for you to
understand what they're going through
you're gonna have to install windows no
that's that's that's that's not the
announcement at least in like a boot
camp i know exactly what they think they
think that as they've said
that police are hunting down black
people and that's just mathematically
not
possible only it's just not true there's
probably
instances of profiling that's a fact
their racism absolutely exists their
racist cops these things happen
but to go out and burn down for white
progressives to go to black
neighborhoods and burn these buildings
down
it's not a matter of me not getting it i
understand why they're angry and they're
wrong
so there's no level where i compromise
it's an emotional thing the issue is not
about whether or not i understand them
the issue is flat out like
i reject them burning down black
businesses in atlanta
i reject it outright and i will not
compromise with it i think so there's no
bringing these two groups together when
one says that they believe they have the
right
white progressives to go to atlanta and
destroy and burn down black
black businesses you see those rappers i
forgot the guy's name where he was like
why are you doing this to us
and they just don't give they don't care
at all and so i say i reject the
destruction that they bring upon these
communities
and that makes me right-wing and their
left-wing there is no point at which i
sit down and i say
so tell me what you want to burn down
next okay what if you only burn down
half that's never going to happen you
got to understand why they feel that way
i know why they feel that way because
the media lies to them and because they
have no idea what's really going on
that's that's not the issue though the
issue is if someone believes
they have a right to do something and i
believe that they don't
and they're wrong there is no us coming
together
the divergent realities cannot coexist
and it's leading to street violence
and it's leading to mass media
propaganda and then like the media
just puts out garbage fake stories
because it makes them money
they rile up these people into believing
crazy things for crazy reasons
and then if you come out and say that's
not true you're right-wing
for example one of the categories for
there's something called transparency
tube
that like charts who's left and who's
right
if you believe that uh brett kat they
lied about brett kavanaugh you're
right-wing
if you if you believe that you know if
you talk about migrant caravans
and you're critical in any capacity
you're right-wing is it a website called
transparency
and it charts all these different
youtube channels it's right-wing to say
they they lied about brett kavanaugh
because the right
tribe says this is crazy and the left
tribe says brett kavanaugh is you know a
gang abuser
so that's that's clearly brett kavanaugh
is not
he was vetted to become a federal judge
that was clearly not true
the woman had no evidence none of it was
corroborated but they go
nuts on that and nothing on hunter biden
so you're right wing if you say
wow hunter biden clearly did something
and brett kavanaugh didn't that's right
wing
so how do you compromise if someone sits
down and says okay
we will allow hunter biden to be
arrested for his transgressions but
we're also going to arrest brett
kavanaugh for being a gang abuser
you're going to be like but brett
kavanaugh didn't do that well we got to
compromise right
no it's not going to happen there's not
going to be a compromise between those
positions
that's because you cannot compromise
about truth and it comes down to
what is true and what is not and they
live in canada
you ever see that meme where it's like a
square from one angle but the other
angle the edges are rounded so it looks
like a circle
and then you see the shadows on the wall
and both shadows are right
they're both true but one person sees
two guys
looking at a six and a nine yeah well
it's very similar so truth is relative
to how you perceive the situation
well no there are people who believe
they know the truth based on limited
information but some things are just
true
i i don't so the the the uh available
body of evidence on say brett kavanaugh
would not bring us to a position beyond
a reasonable doubt that brett kavanaugh
did anything wrong
there's just no evidence in fact there's
evidence of the contrary
her friends were saying they don't
recall what she's talking about and they
don't think they even knew brett
yet she still carried on the democrats
still said he did it
and now there and now you still have the
left saying i can't believe that
that rapist is now on the supreme court
it's like they never presented literally
any evidence
the only evidence that came out was that
she was probably lying about some things
like when she said
she was scared to fly and then she was
asked didn't you fly to like the bahamas
or something and she goes yes
okay like i thought you were scared to
fly apparently not
so they they have no no leg to stand on
but they just believe it it's the true
nana shabbat of pressure
phenom i'm going to call it that true
it's the true nana shabbat pressure
phenomenon where the left will just
cheer for
anything so long as it's blue period
they don't want to be afraid anymore i
think but at the very
bottom even beneath the operating system
thing i think just
on the humans as an organism can't stand
to be afraid for too long they will
jump on any they say there's that saying
any port in a storm
i don't want to be afraid anymore hey
government hey tv
hey cnn just tell me something so that i
don't have to be afraid anymore tell me
what i need to do or say
do i need to go enchant with this group
of people over here fine i just don't
want to be afraid anymore
you for instance kavanaugh i feel like
they're not attacking him as a person
they don't know him as a person
but they're attacking the symbol the
symbol of a right-leaning judge
in a majority possible well now it's a
majority
a right-leaning majority that means that
it will take away
certain freedoms from them that they
value more than
their own safety and the safety of
others they will become violent because
they are convinced
that that symbol being in a position of
power means
their lives and other lives will be
ruined they're afraid of what will
happen so they have to attack
the symbol they're attacking trump but
they're not really attacking trump
they're attacking
what he symbolizes well the media
painted him as this this image
well so that's why they loved him before
he ran
yeah he was funny before but now he's in
a position of power that's very scary
people don't want to be scared so then
ultimately the issue is we have two
divergent realities one
where the media just ignores the
constitution and says joe biden won when
he didn't
and he probably it looks like he's on
track two win that's fine
but we're nowhere near that point we're
a month away from an actual winner
in this uh in the traditional
constitutional process the media just
doesn't care
so now you have one side saying let the
process play out we're still waiting
it's like
but the other side's saying it's not
true and all these people just believe
it there's divergent realities
and so the idea that we could come
together to me seems just
not possible regarding the people that
would give up their freedom
and that seek safety or freedom i think
that's literally like a thomas jefferson
quote it might have been jefferson
sure uh those that are willing to give
up their freedom i think safety
is incorrectly attributed to better
franklin franklin deserve neither safety
nor freedom what
who i know is both yeah who who was that
attributed to is that
i think it was falsely attributed to ben
franklin but i don't know the origin of
it
basically if you give up your freedom
for security you're going to lose all of
it those that would
be storming into your house and dragging
your wife out by your hair and looking
for the
the noise behind the tv it's you don't
want to give up your freedom
that was the idea it's like saying what
what words what prayer do i have to say
do i have to go to confession i don't
mean to speak against religion
some religions are very good i think but
what do i have to say or do
do i have to give money light a candle
whatever to just make the guilt the pain
the the the fear go away just tell me o
priest
or tell me oh group what do i need to do
to make it go away there's something
very deep in the organism of humans
that's beneath culture it's just the
whole organism of humans
we need to go to an external source
because i think we punish ourselves a
lot
with with fear and guilt and sort of uh
for instance if i'm if i grow up in a
really rich family
i have a certain guilt i didn't but
let's say i feel a certain guilt because
i had certain privileges that other
people don't
i can then be convinced by let's say a
very charismatic person that
hey i grew up with all these privileges
therefore i should feel guilty and
therefore i should
give away everything i have and then
serve
a certain group of people that i think
are underprivileged
which could be a good thing that can
make my guilt go away that's a
potentially good thing
but if you apply that to a certain
ideology that says
all people who are doing well are evil
and are stealing
you are now taking that guilt and
turning it you're almost weaponizing it
people can be converted because of guilt
feelings they can be converted into
weapons which i
we've seen with communists and socialism
i can understand why
on its surface it seems attractive but
when you see
there's that saying you can know a tree
by its fruit when you see what happens
years down the road to these countries
no the gulag archipelago for instance
you see what happens to
anyone who's doing better than anyone
else they are now a target because
clearly they they stole it they took
advantage of somebody else
so anytime i'm doing better than the guy
next to me
i have to feel guilty and then that
person
has uh an advantage over me of like a a
moral superiority
i'm be i'm below that person they're
doing better than me therefore
uh i don't know communism is well i can
get away with stealing from him so for
instance you'll see
uh the rioters and the looting they'll
someone once told me um
it's okay to steal from like walmart
because you know they're doing so well
as
because they steal from their workers
right and it doesn't matter you're still
stealing that's the point you're
breaking the law and
lawlessness leads to all kinds of like
other problems and there's a million
reasons not to do it it's wrong
but they're justifying it and saying
that person was not doing well
off when you start excusing
what we're calling it crime when you
excuse it
you start going into all these things of
like well if i just turn the other way
well some guy got clubbed over the head
but he deserved it i'm sure he deserved
it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you